maybe let's zoom out look at the
standard model of pH of particle physics
how does Dark Matter fit into first of
all what is it can you explain what the
standard model is so the standard model
of particle physics is basically tells
us about Nature's most basic elements
and their interactions and so it's the
substructure as far as we understand it
so if you look at atoms we know they
have nuclei and electrons nuclei have
protons and neutrons in them protons and
neutrons have particles called quirks
that are held together by something
called the strong force they interact
through the strong force the strong
nuclear force there something called the
weak nuclear force and
electromagnetism so basically all those
particles and their interactions
describe many many things we understand
that's the standard model we now know
about the Hig boson which is asso
assciated with how Elementary particles
get their Mass so that P of the puzzle
has also been
completed we also know that there are
kind of a weird array of masses of
Elementary particles there's not just
the up and down Quirk but there are
heavier versions of the up and down
Quirk charm and strange top and bottom
there's not just the electron there's a
muon and a tow there are particles
called neutrinos which are under intense
study now which are partnered with the
leptons through the weak interactions so
we really do know these basic elements
and we know the forces we know I mean
when we're doing particle physical
experiments we can usually even ignore
gravity except in exceptional cases that
we can talk about so those are the basic
elements in their interactions Dark
Matter stands outside that it's not
interacting through those forces so when
we look at the world around us we don't
usually see the effects of dark matter
it's because there's so much of it that
we do and it doesn't have those forces
that we know about but the standard
model has worked spectacularly well it's
been tested to a high degree of
precision people are still testing it
and one of the things we do as
physicists is we actually want it to
break down at some level we're looking
for the Precision measurement or the
energy or whatever it will take where
those where the standard model is no
longer working like not that it's not
working approximately but we're looking
for the deviations and those deviations
are critical because they can tell us
what underlies the standard model which
is is what we really want to see next
where can you find the the places where
the standard model breaks down like uh
what are the what are the places you can
see those tiny little deviations so we
don't know yet but we know the kinds of
things you would want to look for so one
obvious place to look is at higher
energy um we're looking at the large
hron collider but we'd love to go beyond
that higher energies means shorter
distances and it means things that we
just couldn't produce before I mean e
equal mc^2 so if you have a heavy
particle and you don't have enough
energy to make it you you'll never see
it so that's one place the other place
is precision measurements if you you
know the standard model has been tested
exquisitly so if been if it's been
tested at 1% you want to look at a tenth
of a percent and there are some
processes that we know shouldn't even
happen at all in the standard model or
happen a very suppressed level and those
are other things that we look for so all
of those things could indicate there's
something beyond what we know about
which of course would be very
exciting when you just step back and
look at the standard model the quirks
and all the different particles and n
trinos
and isn't it wild how this like little
system came came to being creates is
underpins everything we see absolutely
and that's why we'd like to understand
it better we want to know is it part of
some bigger sector um why are these
particles why do they have the masses
they do yeah um why is the hi bosen so
light compared to the mass it could have
had which we might have even expected
based on the principles of special
relativity in quantum mechanics so
that's a really big question why are
they what they are and they originate
there's like some mechanism that created
the whole thing that's one of the things
we're trying to study why is it what it
is I mean even just like the mechanism
that creates stuff like the way a human
being is Created from a single cell it's
like embryo Genesis like the whole thing
like bu you build up this thing all of
it the this whole thing comes to be from
just like a don't forget it is
interacting with the environment for
sure okay right right right it's not
it's right it's important well that's a
really good question is how much of it
is the environment is it just the
environment acting on a set of
constraints
and uh like how much of it is just the
information in the DNA or the
information how much is it in the
initial conditions of the universe or uh
versus the the some other thing acting
on it
these are Big questions these are Big
questions in pretty much every field um
you know we for the universe we do
consider it you know it's everything
there is by definition but people now
think about it is it one of many
universes um in of course it's a
misnomer but could there be other places
where there are self-contained
gravitational systems that we don't even
interact with so but those are really
important questions and the only way
we're going to answer them is you know
we go back as far as we can we try to
think theoretically and we try to think
about observational consequences it's
all we can
do